vous regardez les rênes du shopping ou
pas j'ai regardé puis matt en crue ça
vous avez décidé qu'elle où vous allez
faire cet été parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui me pose la question le look
oui à bages attend voir la dernière
émission quand vous serez biais je me
goure mois la cachaine encore au moins
l'année prochaine
à tulle il est vraiment en tout cas la
définition parce que les 1ers dû partir
ensemble en vacances il est vraiment la
définition que la beauté et le
sex-appeal n'ont rien à voir avec les
looks parce que honnêtement tu n'es pas
vu ce qu'on appelle beau temps mais en
riant jabra non merde je suis sur
l'héritage non mais est en revanche
quand on était ensemble
c'est fascinant il a il a un truc toutes
les filles la piscine venez le voir
vienne animera les abords et dégage un
truc extrêmement gentil où je sais pas
il était venu parler oui viennent le
voir alors que il a un peu de ventre il
est sûre le laisser il est sur le
transat on épand n'est pas sur une bombe
vas-y marché il est où le vent marin non
mais c'était avant aux états il se doit
à marcher un peu
j'ai 58 ans ce décalage
c'est très beau si je peux me permettre
gentil je suis est magnifique et il fait
c'est juste la différence avec toi en
fait lui il a un capital sympathie que
toi tu n'as pas donc du coup l'eau des
sabords toi et l'autre c'est souvent h&h
mathieu engagement allô allô va faire
revenir pour se faire insulter et bien
roche c'est bien oui
un match maîtrisé